[Music]
Pierre Connaissa, hello, hello. We're
interviewing you today for a
YouTube channel called Serview. We'd like to
get your
perspective on recent events. What
can you
tell us about them? A little bit of background, and
then a little bit of history.
Well, I worked for about twenty
years at the French Ministry of
Defense in various roles,
all but
administration. Specifically,
strategic affairs, arms exports,
intelligence, and more generally,
thinking about the organization of the
ministry. I left that position in the early
2000s to run a
business intelligence company for about
eight years. And now I'm doing well, I'm
happily retired because I can do what I
want to do, which is
actually writing. I'm free to
speak, if you will. Okay, so the first,
extremely important point, which
will perhaps explain
my way of
thinking more precisely, is that I was working on
strategic affairs in the 90s. The
90s was the time when the USSR...  It's a
bad joke to
disappear, that's what
Gorbachev's advisor said at the Helsinki summit to
the American team: "We're going to do you
the
worst possible service, we're going to deprive you of..."
So it seems like a joke, but in fact,
in the strategic thinking system,
it's obviously traumatic because
how can you think about
risk, threats, or challenges when you
no longer have enemies? That is to say, either
you have temporary layoffs, so you
lay people off and then you think
budgets will decrease, or you create
enemies. What do you mean
by creating enemies? Well, creating
enemies is what everyone saw
appear in the 90s, that is to say,
an American line of thinking consisting,
in particular, of... a burst
of thought, such as the
clash of civilizations, such as
Tington's book, or such as
the end of history,
Fukuyama's book. Each time, it's these
themes.  which I will come back to,
was amplified, picked up, and disseminated by
all the media in all countries. To give
you an example, the book by the author was
translated into 35 languages. Now,
it raised an issue on
which one could have an
extremely important critical distance, since
it assumed that there is a kind of
Arab-Islamic world that was, by
nature, aggressive, and that was obviously the
American point of view on the matter. But from the
moment the book was
disseminated as the new
American thought, it formatted the entire debate. That is to
say, one could only
position oneself for or against the book by this author.
Okay, I'll take another
example: either you are with us or you are
against us. Yes, that's it. So what's
funny is that when Bou
uses the phrase, he transforms the
phrase from the Bible. That is to say, the
phrase from the Bible is "all those who
are not against us are with us,"
and the phrase he uses is "all those who are
not with us are against us." It's a
funny change.  It's
ancient, meaning he was taking the
biblical phrase in its most exclusive form, the one most
likely to create
conflict. So, this other
example, which you might find fascinating, is
Fukuyama's book. He was
one of the mouthpieces in
Iraq, supporting
the American aggression there. His thesis
was simply the end of history, the
liberal democratic model would
triumph. So, ultimately, in a way, there's no
more history. You
've seen the success of the thesis; we ca
n't really say it was a forward-looking
vision that translated
into reality. But what
interested me much more was the way
every time an American book appeared, there was a
kind of
mobilization of all the newspapers,
dailies, news outlets, doing
interviews, debates, and so on. Is this
mobilization or
propaganda? Well, I leave it to the media, how can I put it?
I consider that the
media are free to make their
editorial choices, and therefore I don't take them on board.
For legal professionals, it's
not their area of ​​expertise; they're essentially trying to
capitalize on current events. How news is
created
is another question, but generally speaking, as soon as
you have a topic that generates
buzz, you
immediately get media coverage.
So, what interested me much more was
ultimately how this
strategic production mechanism works. We're all used to
talking about the military-industrial complex, for example. The
military-
industrial complex means the conjunction
of the military with
defense industry, which is supposedly the
war-makers. But I was at the Ministry of
Defense, and what I observed was that
the military wasn't at all
belligerent, firstly because they know what
war is, if you
will. And on the other hand, there was a
kind of military-intellectual complex at work,
composed in particular of "singank" (a term used to describe intellectuals who
produce these famous books) by a
number of media intellectuals and
academics. And then, of course, within
the ministries, there's a
strategic thinking system.
I'm opening up...  As an aside, within
these institutions, did you see a
conjunction of people trained
in the United States or adhering to
American doctrine?
Not at that time. It was more a generational
shift, if you will.
For example,
Sovietologists were already losing
ground since the
Soviet Union no longer existed, and they were desperately fighting
to maintain control over the former
Soviet republics that had become
independent. A major
administrative debate ensued: should the
newly independent Central Asian countries fall under the
Turkic or Persian world, depending on the
language spoken, or should they
fall under the USSR because they
were former Soviet republics?
So, it was amusing because it was a
kind of dispute over
expertise, but it was actually a
power struggle: how could I
remain an advisor to the prince? No, the
generational shift came later. In
particular, it's the generation in
power today, that is, people
who have had this kind of...  The
fascination with American power stems from the fact
that the 1990s were the
decade of hyperpower and
unilateralism. There was no longer a
truly strategic and coherent rival to
the Union, only to the United States. Therefore, at that time, there was
a kind of fascination with
how the majority leader would act, how they would be
followed, what
position to adopt towards them, and
so on. The last vestige
of
French diplomacy, if you will, is
Shirak's reaction of refusing to go to Iraq. After that, everything else
was swept aside:
Sarkozy, Hollande, and so forth. All of this
became a kind of generation of
neoconservatives, partly educated in the
United States, or at least
fascinated by it, who
would follow the Americans even more than the
British, if you will, pretty much
everywhere in the world. Perhaps
a word about the American Young
Leaders on this subject. Listen, what
's very surprising is that this
attitude is completely internalized.  That is to say, there is no longer
any critical distance. They won't
say, "I was trained by the CSIS," or "
I was trained by..." Not at all. It's a
kind of... how to put it... they're almost fellow
travelers, if you will.
As we used to say back in the USSR era,
these are people who retain their intellectual freedom, who have
their freedom
of expression, but who are totally
American-minded
today. And we see this, for
example, in the policy towards
Iran, which is becoming completely
incomprehensible. That is to say, since they didn't
see the American shift, they're going to be
forced to backtrack, if
you will, to say, "But after all,
now we need Iran to
resolve the Iraqi crisis, to
resolve Afghanistan, to resolve the
crises in Lebanon and Syria." So we're
in a situation where, if you
will, the
current generation of strategists is
a generation that is precisely completely out of touch with
reality. So how does this
phenomenon play out? It's quite interesting because,
for example...  In the 1990s, we
were in the midst of the crisis in Yuoslavia.
The crisis in Yuoslavia was
indeed a crisis that
directly concerned us because of the
continental situation, because it was, after all,
one of the countries occupied by
Germany, one of the countries that had suffered the most
from the German occupation, which had had
concentration camps and so on. And
in Yuoslavia, we found a
number of similar behaviors:
Serbian concentration camps to imprison
Croats, gang rapes—we
had all of that. So, this
directly concerned Europeans, and
at the time, Europeans thought that a
Franco-British alliance would be enough to
calm everyone down. At that point, we
discovered that it wasn't even enough to
dissuade the Serbs from doing what they
had to do. So, we realized
the weakness in relation to the
Americans, or rather, in relation to
a middle power like Serbia,
and therefore the necessity of having
American support. This was a time when the
Americans weren't particularly
Bellic, meaning that the Clinton era
was a time when we had to pull them
by the sleeve to get them to come. It was
n't him; he considered it our
business. But we were also in a
period of economic crisis.
Everyone was reducing their
defense budgets, everyone was somewhat
reluctant, the Germans in
particular, to intervene militarily,
and so on. So there's also this shock,
meaning that if we're
not even capable of managing a
European crisis on the scale of the
Yugoslav crisis, then we truly have
two possible options: either we create a
European defense force, but that becomes a
philosophical debate, a bit like the
sex of angels, or we follow
the American path. And that's
the option that was chosen
unconsciously and on which we have
continually declined. So
the French intelligentsia, or
the
Parisian intelligentsia, pushed to go in that
direction. That is to say, it's the
miserabilism of  Impotence is
intellectual miserabilism, it's the
unwillingness to
distance oneself from the
pro-US group. I don't think so. There were
several things. First, there was the
confrontation with reality, realizing that we, as Europeans,
were incapable of managing
a crisis like
Yugoslavia. That's a
dramatic realization. It meant that on
European soil, we weren't even
militarily capable of having a
sufficiently
deterrent interposition force. Don't forget that
the siege of Saravo lasted 1,000 days,
like the siege of Leningrad, mind you. Well, in
other times, obviously.
This realization is already terrible: 2,500
airstrikes. So then, there was indeed,
how to put it, this
kind of force management that meant we didn't want to
engage in
a war. We wanted, at the same time, to
have a sufficiently deterrent action so
that the Serbs wouldn't go too
far, but at the same time,
remember, we let Gorasd do what he wanted. We let  To
carry out occupations,
sometimes with massacres, all of which is
obviously a crisis of
European conscience, since once again it was
an admission of powerlessness. I'm coming back to the fact that
you're talking about the former
Yugoslavia, what do you think of the mass
graves at Timy Soara? Well, that's more of
a question for
journalists. That is to say, when
we're in a situation of
media tension, like the days
we experienced last week, it's
obvious that there's an
overproduction of information. I was a
guest on the EUR 1 set, I think it was
last Thursday or Friday.
Anyway, when the
police and gendarmerie forces decided
to attack the two locations
held by
the terrorists, it was
extraordinary because first
the radio host was commenting on
television images, then he asked his
specialist journalists to comment on the
television footage, and then, since it was
necessary to maintain a kind of
media tension, he would pass the microphone, one minute
to the correspondent who was in
Massin, the next  To the correspondent who was in
Darie, and then the guys, they didn't have much to say.
So the one
in Darie was saying, "Well, yes, there are
two helicopters... no, maybe
three... no, there are maybe two." Well, that's an
example of information that was supposed to be
information about the tension, but
which in fact didn't add anything. And Vincen
is even more of a caricature because the
guy in Vincen was saying, "Well, we're in contact
with the neighbor who lives above
the supermarket. The lady was saying, 'Well, listen,
I have nothing to tell you because first of all,
my windows face the other
side, and then the police
asked me not to close the windows.'
Then he questioned the gas station attendant who
lived across from the hypermarket. The
attendant was saying, 'But I can't tell you anything.'
Shipwreck, the shipwreck of journalism, we're
seeing it clearly with the emergence
of the Internet. The question I'm
asking myself is, where are we going?
That is to say, we have an increase in
threats, the weak signals are...
Red, we have, uh, some captains of
pedalos within the strategic
and foresight cells, we
Europeans get involved in Libyan conflicts, in
Syrian conflicts, and
then, with our mouths full of praise, we
get repercussions and
terrorist attacks on
French soil. So you're telling me
that we're not capable of
managing Kosovo, uh, that we get involved in
wars where the quagmire was
predictable, and and we don't have any more money?
Yes, what interested me a lot,
particularly in the creation of
the enemy, is that I asked myself,
ultimately, what period do we enter
after 1991? Because ultimately, having no more
enemies, why are there still
conflicts?
And I find that, first of all,
Bush's declaration that followed 9/11 is
extremely interesting because, for
the first time, he declares war
on concepts, the war against
proliferation and against terrorism,
which are, once again, not enemies, but
concepts. And TER, concept
in the spin doctor sense, I think that  Yes, if
you like, he shapes
American domination of the world. That is to say, I
give you the agenda, I tell you that we
must fight against
international terrorism—he's the one who invented this
concept—and then he performs this
formidable strategic sleight of hand in which
he calls proliferation the
main threat, even though 11 out of
15 members of the
9/11 attack were Saudis in Iraq. And he says that the "
Attacks of Evil" are Iraq, Iran,
North Korea, and Saudi Arabia.
Nobody talks about it anymore. So that's what's
interesting: how do we
conceive of an enemy that
will shape the Western camp, in this
case, and immediately the
outcome—you know it—the invasion
of Afghanistan. We can
take stock today, and then immediately afterward,
Iraq—the first fracture.
So Afghanistan is interesting
because, with even a minimal amount
of
historical knowledge, everyone broke away.
The teeth on Afghanistan,
it's fantastic, the English in the good old days
of
colonialism, they really did, but then the
English, they arrive all the way to Kabu and
then finally, seeing that they can't
hold the country, they burn down the
Kabu bazaar. There's no bazaar in Kabu today, it's still
fantastic, you have to know that. And then, during the
retreat, they are caught in an
attack at Khmer Pass where
the entire British expeditionary force is exterminated
except for
one. The Afghans send a guy to
tell the others what happened.
No, no, but precisely, it's the
first time that this thing was created,
it wasn't created by the
dominant strategic power, it was created
by a bunch of vanupids who were the
Afghans of the time. The Soviets, 10
years there, the result, you
know it: 4 million refugees in
Pakistan, 2 million refugees in Iran,
and finally they leave Afghanistan, and
completely disregarding that, I
'm pretty certain that the world that surrounded them
at the time of the  The
decision was made by people who, having never even
set foot in
Afghanistan, were saying, "But Afghanistan, we'll
take care of it right away. We'll
catch Ben Ladan, we'll overthrow
Mullah Omar, and you'll see, the
Taliban will be swept away." It's true
that the Taliban were swept away.
The problem is that they weren't
aware that the war was over. You
know, it's like
George Buou's declaration during the invasion of
Iraq. The first phase, the
conventional phase, the regime,
Saddam Hussein's army, was swept away, and then George
Buou gave this fantastic speech on
the aircraft carrier saying, "That's it, we've
won." Well, the problem is that the
others weren't informed that the
war wasn't over, and they
continued. And so, today, to
return to the case of Afghanistan, after
a particularly
catastrophic outcome, since they've been there for 13 years,
the same defense effort as
the Soviets: 6 trillion dollars. 6 trillion
dollars if we count everything.  This is a
point we can come back to if
you like; that is to say, the entirety,
including the cost of the wounded, the cost of
compensation, the cost of the widows, and so on.
And in the 6 trillion, I'm not counting
veterans
and another important strategic aspect:
the extension of the war into Pakistan
because the Soviets were
always forbidden from crossing the
border, while
drone strikes hit the territory, the
tribal areas, and thus the extension of the
war. The outcome of all this, you
know, is a
probable return of the Taliban. So the
Najibula regime, which succeeded the
Soviets—excuse me, you're not talking about it, not at all, not at all, not at all—
and so the, how to put it, the Najibula
that the Russians left in place after
their departure lasted two years. We can bet on
how long the Afghan regime will last
today; the outcome is
catastrophic. For pity's sake, madam, and out of magnanimity,
I won't dwell on
the French operation in Libya, but we
are exactly in that situation.
We'll come back to that, since you brought it up,
BL
Bernard-Henri Lévy,
practically appointed Minister of
Foreign Affairs,
alongside John McCain, in
some photos—or at least not in
some photos, but in the company of
John McCain on the territory. What do
you think of that? So, if
you want, I talked to you about the
generation, or rather, the concept of
war, which was the war against the
concepts. That was...  With
American production today, we are forced to
acknowledge that there is no
strategic threat. Terrorism has never
won a war, so even if
terrorism is serious, if it kills
people, etc., it remains that it is not
a strategic threat on the scale of what
the Red Army was in the
1950s to 2000. So, we are now in
an era where, if we
look at all the conflicts tearing
the planet apart, there are roughly
400. But how do we make this choice to
say which one is serious and which one isn't?
Economic interest isn't the only factor.
Because
you have this category of
people, the
media intellectuals. There are new
opinion-makers on
strategic matters, the first of which are the
media intellectuals, in the
category that includes Bernard-Henri Lévy (BHL),
first point. But there are also
humanitarians who tell you, "I know the
victims, therefore I know the perpetrators."
And then you have the
diasporas who will tell you, "In the name of..."  The
suffering I endured 50
years ago—I'll explain why
our country must commit to this or
that category. For example, if you want to talk about the
diaspora, it was the Armenian diaspora
that succeeded in getting that
stupid law passed, making France recognize
the genocide in which it played
absolutely no part, so it can
go around lecturing
others. But are we going to
pass a law on the genocide of the
Indians, for example? Out of the
question. Are Algerians going to
pass a law on the genocide of the
FLN fighters for France? No, out of the
question. So you see this
habit of people who will tell you, "
France absolutely must recognize," that there is
a force of
pressure. Victimology is an
important lever, if you will, for determining
the axes of foreign policy. So,
these three
opinion leaders are the ones who interested me because they
speak directly to
politicians; they don't go through analyses
saying, "Invention, the most
extraordinary concept that has been invented recently."
Well, you remember...
Humanitarian intervention in Somalia, yes,
humanitarian intervention, it was the warlords,
international aid to Somalia, to the
poor people of Somalia, and so it is
absolutely necessary to make a defense effort
to
re-establish a central power that would
finally manage aid to the population. Well, plus
several errors, first the "
me" strategy, because
ultimately we saw that if I take a step back,
if today everyone doesn't care what is
happening in Somalia, so there was indeed
a media moment that
had sparked "me" and called on
politicians to do something. It's
generally the thin little child
holding out their hand for a little
rice, it can be that. So you have
different "me" strategies, you
have women, rape, little children, little girls,
child soldiers, and so that's
the media channel through which it
passes, but at the same time you
have the
media intellectuals who will tell you we cannot not,
the double negative
that will explain that we absolutely must
go, and so we invent with Coucher
and Betati the idea...  Humanitarian management—
so why humanitarian management?
It's very interesting because
humanitarians had the wind in their
sails since the 1960s, since
Biafra. It was the type of
non-state international action that
everyone identified with, so there was
political capital that absolutely had to be
recovered. And so
the concept of humanitarian intervention was invented, that is
to say, associating the
military with humanitarian aid. So the
concept of humanitarian bombing—that's
not just bombing, it means equipping, how to
say, associating
humanitarian convoys with armed forces. This is because
humanitarian workers have
always denounced it, saying, "No, what we need for
our security is not to
be armed, to appear
non-belligerent." And so this
militarization, which was mainly initiated
by Coucher, was, "We are going to
militarize humanitarian action." Well,
you know the rest. Today,
humanitarians have become
targets by force of circumstance,
since no one can...
Consider them independent, then, having
listened to some bearded
individuals who attack
humanitarian organizations, they tell me, "
We're attacking them because there are
strong suspicions of
intelligence service infiltration within
these
humanitarian efforts. It's probable, it's possible, it might be
true, it
might not be true, I don't know." But the mere
fact that suspicion
exists, just as it does regarding journalists,
justifies the same type of
hostile behavior. And so, where
humanitarians were protecting themselves precisely
through their professed pacifism,
the question arises as to how
the belligerents will behave.
But the fundamental upheaval is
this concept of humanitarian intervention, which
will translate in Somalia into
American troops landing in
Somalia in the middle of the night, under the flashes and
glare of
television journalists. These guys are crawling on the
ground with their faces blackened, and at the
same time, they're all around...
From them, journalists filmed them
live so that in the United States, people would
know that they were arriving—a
fantastic production, sorry, a fantastic production, yes, a
fantastic production, but
totally contradictory on the
military level. So we were in something
that, obviously, at some point, would end up
clashing. The second
aspect that seems very interesting to me
is the lack of political analysis on
the crisis that we will find in Libya, that we
will find in Syria, and so on.
Why? Because political analysis
requires a minimum of looking
back before making a decision. But
the media perspective is not the
strategic perspective, you know. If a politician
is called upon, you can't help but be approached
by a media intellectual, by
humanitarians, and so on. He will decide in an
emergency. So why insist on
Somalia? Because Somalia is like
Afghanistan; it's the country that
resisted colonization in exactly the
same way: tribal structures,
everyone is armed, and therefore
security is ensured by your tribe.
So the colonizer who arrives can
be either an ally or an enemy.  But in
any case, alliances
vary. There was an Afghan warlord
who said something I
still find wonderful: "You can't
buy an
Afghan warlord, but you can rent him." It's a
fantastic saying. It means
you're in an alliance system where
your allies and
enemies are negotiated daily. Somalia is the same. So why was the
case of Somalia a caricature?
This country, reconstituted in the
1950s by joining
Italian and British Somaliland,
is a country where there was
immediately a
military coup. Siad Baré ruled Somalia for 50 years,
using all the means
of public force to repress
ethnic identities. This means that
for the Somalis who had managed to get
rid of Siad Baré, their only
objective was to avoid a
central state. Because if you put a
central state in place, it means it will have the
means of force and therefore will
behave the same way as Siad
Baré. And so we arrived at...  The
white knight, saying we'll
help you rebuild a central state, the
guys thought, yeah, there's
always a bit of money to be made, so
we'll go to the Aidasabeba conference.
But fundamentally, their own logic was,
how do I remain
independent in my political space? And
that raises a serious question: there
may be territories on the
planet where there is no
central state. So, you see, it's this
political obstacle that means we no
longer know what to do. In this case,
I'll draw a parallel with
Libya. Libya, let's say, had six
tribes that were federated by
Gaddafi. After his coup, Gaddafi
fell, power decentralized, and the
warlords wanted access to the
resources under their
feet. We're there, and
it's starting to annoy the
citizens, at least those
citizens with ties to or, let's
say, a respectful view
of Islam, who see children being
bombed under the false pretext...  Because we were
going to Libya to
save the orphan of the Great
Tyrant, the war for peace, HM, this grand
concept, uh, we're there now,
Syria, uh, kids from the suburbs
with one foot between two continents, uh,
look at it with skepticism,
except that this generation is
connected to the internet and also
influenced by the internet and also finds,
uh, journalistic lies a bit
hard to swallow,
uh, we've just received strikes
on our territory, hm, hm, we understand
that for the last 30 years,
armchair geopolitics is starting to
have repercussions, uh, on the
ground, the military who know about
overseas operations know the price of blood,
yes, and French citizens are
now starting to feel the price of
blood on their own soil, what do we do? Well,
first we stop and think,
as GB used to say, huh, it's still always
useful, which isn't
the current mood, huh? The current mood, having
participated in a
number of television programs, is that
politicians come to
acknowledge declarations that they  They're going to do this
now so they can say in six months, "
I told you so." The theme is, we
need to increase the budgets of the
intelligence services, the police,
the army, and so on and so forth—
things I'm not disputing. But that's not what I call stopping and thinking.
Stopping and thinking is about understanding the connection
between foreign policy,
integration problems, relations with the
Muslim community, and so on. You see what I mean? That, in
my opinion, is the real
means of reflection, where a smile
costs less than a bullet. That's it. Well, it's not only that. It's
also
the fact that, obviously, the past
act of violence is legitimate.
Obviously, choosing
Jewish targets is unacceptable in itself, but
what does it reflect? That's
the real question. Is it a
question you're asking yourself, or is it a question you're
asking? No, no, I'm asking myself the question,
but I'm calling on
French politicians, if you will. That is to say...  What we
need to know at this point is what the
psychiatric theme is, if you will,
on the theme of "they don't care" and so on, it's
not my
problem. So, at this point, we need to
question the relationship that
French society has fostered in these
young people. Yes, so we're going to
broaden the scope a little, the fact of
classifying terrorists as having a
psychiatric pathology...
I find it rather far-fetched, given
the operation that
was mounted. That is to say, you are
facing extremely well-prepared, extremely heavily armed people
who practice... let's take the
case of the Hyper Cacher supermarket at Porte de
Vincennes... it's the same
intimidation technique as the attacks on
market squares in Iraq. That is to say, on market
days, people come to
stock up because, well, it's
market day, there are no hypermarkets
there, and they strike on
market days to terrorize the population.
Samintandé, the area is a
Jewish area, or at least one with a large Jewish community,
where everyone lives in harmony. I
know the neighborhood very, very well. There, we
see politicians saying they're
crazy instead of having a
much more
structured perspective, saying, "Look, we
made mistakes. The people on the other side
organized themselves and are now attacking, fueled by
the psychosis our own violence has
generated in them." Because we're aware of the
caricatures of
crazy people
shooting at people.
However, I'm coming back to your point of view:
what is
the introspection of the
intelligence forces in the face of VAT-era,
hyper-security-driven politicians? No, I don't agree with
your question because it's not the
intelligence service's role to question the
politicians' stance. They
have a mandate, a mission. We'll
give them, if you want, an
intelligence plan. Well, the question is,
how do we get
politicians to engage in the
work you're talking about? They're the ones with
the real power.  One
can play one's role as an
intellectual, one can play one's role
among colleagues in
administrative services, and so on, but it's
clear that a part of the language
is restricted when one is within the
administration. You can't say to
your Minister, "Excuse me, Mr.
Minister of Foreign Affairs, but there are a number
of
topics for intervention that need to be addressed." No
one has
officially regretted
the military intervention in Libya, for
example. Remember, it was the
best day in the world for the previous
president, and then Mali became
the best day in the world for the
current president. So we have a
kind of triumphalism as soon as it
touches on military matters, which,
if you will, clouds the mind. That's what
happened to us after 1918. We had the
best army in the world; you know
the rest of the story. So this type of
reflex must be understood;
that is to say, you have to get inside
people's heads. There isn't always time for
reflection.  So, to get back to your
question, it's true that today there has been
this kind of resistance to
collective mobilization for freedom of expression, for
the defense of Charlie Hebdo, and so on, and
why there have obviously been these terrorist attacks.
Well, I was, following a
conversation with Valls, the Minister of
the Interior, remarking that it was
surprising that there wasn't a
counter-radical policy
in France. What I meant by that was that we
had
problems with a certain part
of the Muslim community, but that we
were always in a kind of trench warfare.
One minute it was about the veil, the next it was about the burqa, then this, then that,
and so on. Well, what
really struck him,
because all of a sudden he said to himself, "Yes, it's
true that it's worth thinking about this," that is to
say, what
policy should we adopt? It turns
out that, as the policy we didn't have...
My
report was published in 2016, and then the
attacks happened in January. So, what was
my initial reflection on Mohs became a
reflection on
the aftermath. Why am I emphasizing this?
Because my subject isn't
how to bring
a transcendent being back down to earth—that is, how to bring
the Kashi brothers back down to earth if they
were still alive. Bringing them back down to earth
isn't about
civics lessons. And with Coulibaly, it's certain that we could have given
him all the
civics lessons he could have received; we even
allowed him to meet the President of the
Republic, but that's not what stopped him. So, there's
a real problem,
a problem with the relationship between
French society and its
Muslim component, with its
administrative organization, and with its
foreign policy. And it's these three
aspects that interested me:
where do these people come from? Why did
these men reach this state of
violence? What led them to this point?
Obviously, you have the
interface.  That is to say, what is
happening on jihadist websites, and so on
and so forth? So my point isn't
to say what the
intelligence services should do, or what the police
should do, and so on, but rather what
politicians should do. Okay, I'll
give you some examples that might
clarify things better than my explanation.
All the major Western countries
today have a counter-
radicalization policy, especially the
Europeans; it's not
generally a problem for the Americans. These policies were
born after a traumatic shock: the
London bombings in Great Britain, the caricature
of Muhammad in Denmark, the death of Thomas van
Gogh in the Netherlands. At that time,
politicians were challenged, and they
reacted intelligently, saying to themselves, "
Ultimately, our model is in
trouble, our model of integration
is in trouble, so we need to think
about how to behave so that
we all contribute together to
deradicalization and
counter-radicalization." This
translated into three things: first,
a public discourse, that is to say...  He
designates the target because
French policy has never done this,
remember Mali, that was
international terrorism, the Central African Republic is
international terrorism, well,
international terrorism is everywhere. That doesn't
mean we have to stop all
the bastards and corsairs, that's
not the point. You see, we don't say
what the target is,
whereas in Great Britain and the Netherlands,
they have designated it. Why this
designation? Because the designation
allows the
Muslim community as a whole to understand
that it is not the entire community that is being targeted, but
a part of
it whose practices,
ideologies, and so on are being denounced. This is extremely
important to avoid the kind of
unconscious stigmatization that
every Muslim today has the
right to feel. Beyond
public discourse, there is an organization, an organization
that generally relies on
local authorities. Why?
Because the person who knows best what is
happening in their municipality is not
the prefect, it is the mayor. The mayor has
social workers, the municipal police,
the Bureau  In terms of social assistance, there's the
Educational Assistance Office, and so
on, and therefore there's contact with
the imam,
the local Muslim association, and so forth.
This network is an alert network, and
then, how to put it, the state could
provide resources. This means, depending on the
case reported, if it's a
family problem that explains a
child's sudden conversion, well, it could be a social
worker, it could be an imam, it could be a
social worker, and so on. So the state
provides resources, but it's not the state as an
actor, which is exactly the
opposite of what France did
after last spring when the
parents of children who had gone to Syria said, "
We have no one to talk to. We
saw our son become radicalized. We saw him
disappear one day. We went to the
prefecture, we went to the courthouse, we went to the
police station, but
nobody helped. Everyone told us, 'I
'm not responsible.'" The
immediate, specifically French reaction was to
say, "Well, it's up to the state to take care of it."
So the state...  In France, who is responsible
for religious affairs? It's the
Ministry of the Interior, that is to say, the
Ministry of the
Interior and Religious Affairs, you see.
And so the office of religious affairs, which is
precisely the normal point of contact for
all religions, finds itself in the
same administration as the
police office, or rather, the police and the
domestic intelligence services. So that's not right. At some point, we have to realize that this isn't
a
crime problem. Then, we entrusted
the organization and coordination to a
committee called the
Interministerial Committee for
Crime Prevention, and we relied on the
network of prefectures.
So we find all the typical
French biases: it's left to the state, which in
my opinion is a mistake. It's the
public network that should be handling it, which is a
mistake. So you see why
I'm positioning myself upstream. And in
parallel with this, we see, for
example, Qatar and Saudi Arabia doing
exactly what some
humanitarian organizations do, with a green flag, providing
funds, giving money to associations.
They're doing what you're saying,
but in the opposite direction. B: they have
a local policy; they have money
coming in locally to...
Local projects allow people to
embrace certain theories and become
radicalized. What do you think about that? So
why in
France, why don't we monitor capital flows, and
why do we tolerate this
type of capital coming from the
most rigorous interpretation of Islam,
namely Saudi Arabia? And behind it all,
we have a
completely schizophrenic relationship. So,
if you want to discuss the
question of targeting,
I believe we need to
revisit a number of
extremely important historical episodes.
Political Islam is more about the
Muslim Brotherhood at the beginning of the 20th century, Hassan
al-Albani, and so on. Even if there was already
a kind of legitimization of the use
of the audience, it doesn't matter. We're in
a period where this violence was
mainly directed against
local powers, against Mubarak, and so on.
Well, the Muslim Brotherhood made a
major mistake, in particular, by showing
solidarity with Saddam Hussein during
the war.  Kuwait, which for the
Saudis is, how shall I say, a state
of absolute insurrection. Well,
second point, which also
proves, if you will, our lack
of attention: when the Americans
were helping the Afghan jihadists against
the Soviets, all American aid went through
Saudi Arabia and the
Pakistani intelligence services. We didn't look into it, but
we reported it, but nobody wanted to give it importance. That
all this
aid went instead to the most
radical factions of the Afghan jihadists, the "
ghoudun-dun-matyar." The point is that giving
money to the most radical,
absolutely systematically, meant they were
better equipped because, obviously, on
their own turf, their donations
gave them an advantage, and so on. And the
second aspect, which we also haven't focused on,
is that the
Saudis stipulated that the
entire dominant doctrinal school in
Pakistan, which was
rather, let's say, not tolerant, but rather
more open, shifted towards
Islamism.  which is the
dominant ideology of Saudi Arabia, and we
saw the Taliban on the ground 10 years later, that is to
say, the
theology students, and so this by-product
that we thought was a kind of
outgrowth, an abscess, we didn't really know,
no, it's the result of a
strategy, a strategy in
which we reasoned in binary terms: the
enemy of our enemy is our friend,
so Saudi Arabia being against it, it's
a friend. But in fact,
Saudi Arabia had its own strategy, and the
same remark about what you're
saying, that is to say, from the
80s, 80s, 90s, the Saudis, considering that it was
necessary to provide imams in the
mosques of France since the
French government refused to
take this variable into account,
spread these imams, in Africa, in
France, in Western countries, these
imams, in this case Salafists,
we must call them by their name, and we
let it happen completely. The only
initial reaction was, in fact,
Sarkozy one fine day  banning an imam
invited to the Bourget summit for
the annual Bourget meeting,
simply because when you
looked at this guy's website, it was the
most brutal and, how can I
say, undisguised antisemitism,
and that's what allowed him to
ban this guy from coming. So what
you're saying is also how, at a certain point,
we implement in
domestic policy barriers that we don't
want to take in
foreign policy, which is still an
important question. And so today, to
designate the principle is to designate what
Salafism is, that is to say, it's
a totalitarian ideology, like many we saw in the
20th century, only this one
wasn't born here, it
was born in Saudi Arabia, and when, if you
will, if we want to defend
Islam as a religion of peace and
tolerance, it's better not to have
Saudi Arabia on our side. That is to say,
if Saudi Arabia is in the
American camp, how come? Well, yes,
I agree with you, but you
see, this yatus, the most
obvious yatus being the war in Iraq where we're going to
fight the Islamic State because it
beheads, it cuts off the hands of thieves,
it oppresses women, and it forbids
other religions, to go and defend
Saudi Arabia, which beheads, cuts off the
hands of thieves, oppresses
women, and forbids other
religions... we could do
another show on the subject where,
moreover, we could debate what's
happening a little bit in the string of
pearls, the rosary, where there's
American security that's starting to
lock down the
Chinese energy sector, but anyway, to discuss this, I have
a question concerning the aftermath. We
see our government, we see
Bernard Cazeneuve, we see the President of
the Republic asking for solutions,
and among these solutions, we saw...
the French Patriot Act. So, I'll give
a little reminder for our
listeners: the Patriot Act, with all the
consequences it had in the United
States on civil liberties and
on the deployment of...
So now we're seeing a French version of the Patriotact,
internet surveillance that's becoming a carbon copy
of what's happening in the United States, and
clearly the export of the
American Patriotact to European territory. What do
you think about
internet surveillance? Is it
part of
counter-radicalization policies? Is it
legitimate? Won't
we, the common people, suffer
collateral damage from
this short-sighted policy that's
reacting in such a symptomatic way?
What do you think? First, I'd
like to draw your attention to the
fact that internal security policy
is culturally
extremely different in major
democracies. For example, the British have long
considered
having an identity card an
intrusion into privacy,
and the Americans do the same,
considering the
driver's license issued by each state to be
the form of identification. As for us, we have
n't considered identity cards for a long time.  that it's an intrusion into
our private lives and a control of our
security. Conversely, the British
had installed cameras on almost
every street in London, while
we were saying that cameras are
unacceptable surveillance, and so on. So
each of us made part of the
connection, but this is to show you how
sometimes these "rights of the
people" speeches, if you will, don't realize how... well, how they
are
very... how to say... very relative. If you
like, I'll give you an example
because I like to provoke, but I was in
Sarayevo shortly after the
end of the war. Will we have the
right to provoke a... of course, of course, I was in
Sarayevo after the
end of the war. The central government
had to establish a kind
of administration taking into account the
Serbian component, the
Bosnian component, the Croatian component, and so on,
after a gigantic humanitarian catastrophe. Come out of the
office I
was entering, a European sexual association
came to ask the
president of the new
Bosnian republic what the rights of
homosexuals are in...  In Bosnia today,
if this law doesn't adapt to
European law, we will oppose your
entry into the European Union. Can you
imagine the kind of shock this
president felt, thinking, "Wait, I have
200,000 displaced people for
whom I have to make an
effort, I have to find
international humanitarian aid,
I have to establish an administration,
I have to create an armed force?" And
you see, the thing is, I don't
want to criticize the rights of
homosexuals, but there has to be a
hierarchy that corresponds, on
the issue of security as well as on the
issue of human rights, to the
priorities that are the
urgent priorities. So, in the case of the
Patriot Act, there are two parts to the
Patriot Act. There's a domestic part,
which is obviously a part where I do
n't get the impression that the Americans
feel particularly monitored,
because
otherwise, the Americans would be...
wait, no, no, but there are two things
precisely, and that's why I
want to emphasize this. And then there's
a part...  Internationally, and it was the
international aspect that was the most
restrictive because, for example, the
Patriot Act mandated that all
container traffic, which was
thought to be the primary means of transporting
threats to American territory, be subject to the
most rigorous control. This
translated into the fact that
the
Americans limited the number of
international ports authorized to
load containers bound for the United States.
For France, only one
port was authorized to do this:
Le Havre, and with the presence of
American customs officials on site. For
example, a second example was the
passenger list with their descriptions,
geography, and so on, for
planes arriving in the United States. So, the
most scandalous aspect of the Patriot Act
was the constraints
imposed on others, particularly regarding
all banking financial data.
Every time there was a
transfer of money to the United States,
the foreign bank had to
report the origin of the money, who
the owner was, and so on. And obviously, there was
no exchange of information.  The
Patriot Act was a fantastic way,
if you will, to capture
a large portion of
international data for the benefit of the United States. In the
French Patriot Act, I doubt we'd be able to
impose the same
constraints on our partners, so we're
only focused on the domestic aspect. You see,
it's important, as they say, the
juicy part is the
juicy domestic aspect, indeed.
That said, if you break it down,
internet surveillance
is what we do in the fight
against pedophilia, for example.
I can ask you a
quick question: what do you know about
fighting pedophilia online?
Because, to be honest, we
're a network of hackers, yeah, yeah, and we
hunt down pedophiles
day and night, and we
find them, especially without making baseless accusations.
We find them mainly in
environments where there's money,
where there's a network, and when we try to flush
them out, we encounter a
lot of resistance. So,
the attraction of the internet regarding
packet inspection...  All these
kinds of measures, uh, no, no,
but wait, let me
focus on the legislative aspect, okay? It's
not about the effectiveness of the system, the
fact that we monitor the internet, just like we
abuse, how should I
say, press law after the
1881 law, the adaptations we've made
successively, and so on. I don't
feel, if you will, that our
freedoms are threatened when we take
measures against racism, against
incitement to racial hatred, and
so on on the internet. It's a medium
you know better than I do, but it's
a medium that we can
imagine, at least, being limited by a
certain number of legislative practices.
Then, that these practices are
effective, applicable, and so on. What do
you think about the fact that it's
not controlled by a judge? Oh, well, no, no,
wait, we're not going to talk about the
legislative framework that hasn't been
adopted yet, but you see that regarding
wiretapping, the problem is the
military programming law has passed,
Article 20 has passed, uh,
we're at the point of accumulating
data.  Of people with
predictive software behind them, uh, you
as a citizen, what does that matter to
you? Does it concern you? Doesn't it concern
you? If I tell you, for
example, that for €2.50 I have access to my
voter registration file, and on my
voter registration file I know the
place of birth, that is to say, I
am able to locate, for example,
all the Moroccans in my city, and indeed
all the Moroccans who
earn more money than the
community. That is to say, if I see a
place of birth called "Parakeche" in the nice
neighborhood of my city, I know that this
Moroccan has made a little more
money than the others. If,
overnight, I want to do the same thing
on Jews, on homosexuals, on
Black people, on people with white hair
in a red tie who blow their nose, I can do it
in 48 hours maximum, I would say
24. What does that matter to you? Yes,
but is it the internet itself
or is it the
law that  The National Assembly is about to vote on what
allows this, that's my
question: is it the tool or the
vector? Yes, that's the
question. The fact that the internet is now such a
powerful tool for penetrating
people's private lives, because by cross-
referencing a number of files, not
all of which are state-owned of
course, this possibility of access... this is
a question that concerns you as much as
the legislator. So, as a
citizen, yeah, what do you
think about giving razor blades to
a monkey? I mean, the
economic situation, the
economic tensions are very significant.
Governments change, but the
tools remain. You're talking about
legislative tools,
legislative tools? No, but precisely, the debate
today is about adapting
the legislative tool. So, that's an
important point. What interests me
more on strategic issues
is how,
excuse me, how, are we
going to complain today about the fact that there is
cyber interference from the Chinese or
the North Koreans?  As revealed
by the Assange case, the most
formidable tool for eavesdropping and
computer penetration was American—that is,
our main ally. So
my question, as a
strategist, is how it is that
a debate, which seems
essential to me, is extinguished at one point to give rise to another,
which seems much less important.
So your question is indeed that:
who is currently capable
of exercising a certain
democratic regulation on the internet? Is it
the legislator or is it
the hackers? We saw with Anonymous that it's more often the hackers.
This is still
a formidable political challenge.
We can clearly see that with Assange, today
he is more persecuted than Abu
al-Da'd or Abu Hamza, who
were the instigators of the Londonistan
of Illes.
How can we explain that we have
surveillance on H,
really the sock, while the
Kashi brothers were left to roam free?
No, that is to say, for
Assange, well...  Surveillance has become
physical, meaning that today they
simply prevent him from going out, which
is still... What's
interesting is that... there's
a topic that really amused me:
why do we describe
the same events differently? Well, if you
want, a guy is kidnapped in Colombia
with a ransom demand, it's a
kidnapping; he's kidnapped in Iraq, it's
a hostage-taking; he's detained at
Guantanamo, it's a denial of rights, you
see what I mean? And the same applies to the
same situations: he doesn't have the
right to a lawyer, he doesn't have the right to see
his family, he doesn't have the right to appear
before a judge, and so on. Yet we don't describe the
same things with the same terms. That's
extremely important. Now, in
Sange, that's what seems most
extraordinary to me: without saying it
exactly, you sense a
major destabilization of
surveillance systems in democratic countries
because he revealed something that
was much more important than that.  that
the emirs of Londonistan were spreading,
and it's truly extraordinary
that there isn't a mobilization to
defend Assange by saying, "Wait
until Sweden commits not to
extradite him to the United States, since that's what
he's afraid of. Once
he's in the United States, he'll be
sentenced to 135 years in prison, and there's
little chance he'll actually get out after
those 135 years." That's what's
most extraordinary: that
democratic states
today don't oppose
Assange's extradition, for example. There are
double standards. Oh yes, a
typical example: the guys from Londonistan,
all those emirs who orchestrated the
2004 attacks. England refused
to extradite them to their countries of origin,
Yemen, Jordan, and so on, because
they said they risked the
death penalty. Fantastic! Yet we cooperate with the
United States, which applies the death penalty.
You agree?  Finally, without meaning to be mistaken, that's what I saw.
So you see how they handle this kind
of measure. His name was
Rachid Ramda, whom they asked
England to extradite following the
1994 attacks in the streets of Paris.
For ten years, the British explained that it was a
complex situation, that they had to appeal to the High
Court, and so on. Then, of course,
Ramda's lawyers used every
legal resource. The last
refusal of extradition was explained by
the fact that he risked being tortured
in French police stations. You see what
I mean? I've never heard the
British justice system say that Assange
risks being tortured in the United States.
So we're really in a system of
double standards. And why is
Assange such a, how shall I
say, disturbing figure? This reveals
practices that also
exist in
democratic states where they refuse to
demonstrate that the United States could
be a risk, or even a threat, to
other Western countries.
Economic rivalry, knowledge about  The fact that
political leaders listen to Angela
Merkel is quite something; one doesn't get
the impression that they
intend to monitor Angela Merkel's sex life.
It's obviously the
decision-making processes; that's what
happens in Europe, the European Commission,
and so on.  In the realm
of listening, there was all the means to
master the
world, which opened the debate.
Germany, because they listened to their
chancellor, it's a lack of
courage, what is it? It's a
resignation, it's the
power of indecision, what is it? I don't know,
I honestly don't know,
but it's true that it's a
cowardice that is still unacceptable.
Unacceptable is the term, the way. And
so, since we have all these means,
since we have all these means, we
can therefore ultimately have an attitude,
if we can, and if we don't,
at the level of semiotics, what does that
indicate? I think it's a
very short-term strategic reflection, which is:
we don't get angry with the major ally, it's
very short-term strategy.
I was very interested, for
example, in how, if you
will, General de Gaulle conceived his
diplomatic strategy of rupture.
That is to say, one fine day he said to his
collaborators, "I'm going to recognize the People's Republic of China."
Just imagine,
everyone around him was saying, "General, you ca
n't be serious, the People's Republic of China, the
Americans!" And he said, "We're going to
withdraw from the UT." You can imagine,
people around him were saying, "
Well, in the heat of the moment, he had
the URE repatriated from France." And there you have it. So, if you
want, you have a
certain number of people around you. You have to understand
the sociology of ministerial offices. If you
want, an office surrounding a
minister is like a court surrounding a
king, and the court is composed of courtiers, right?
And so, when you have
people around you who, all
their lives, say, "Ah yes, Mr.
Minister, you're right." Well, for
the two years you're in power, yes,
Mr. Minister, you're right, Mr.
Minister, what a good idea,
Mr. Minister! There comes a point when
you disconnect from reality. The
greatness of Degol was to always have
that reality, that contact
with the reality of
world geopolitics. Well, today, and I  I know he really put himself on the line, right? Well,
today we're in a
generation, like mine, where, if
you want to know the world,
when you're in the upper echelons of
decision-making, it's very simple: you arrive
in a foreign country, the
ambassador's car is waiting for you, takes you to the
embassy, ​​and at the embassy you have
lunch where the ambassador explains
the country to you in two hours. Then you have your
official meetings where you see your counterparts who, of course,
tell you everyone
attaches great importance to
France's position on the issue that
concerns us, and so on. What is
your analysis? In the evening you have an
official dinner. The next day you have
further contact with your
counterparts, and then you get back on
the plane. Okay, so a little Champagne and a
pat on the back, yes, that's it, but above all, what kind of
contact do you have?
Imagine you're going to Israel, going to
Viva, only you see what
I mean, and you're going to New
Delhi, being... what if you're going to Canada?
You're going to the United States, going to...
Washington, suddenly you discover that
racism exists in the United States,
particularly in the fact that
Black people can be killed in the street. I'll just
digress for a moment: the chain of
command within the
intelligence services, there are indeed honorable
contributors on the ground
who gather information.
Take, for example, the
Arab Spring. You were talking about an
economic intelligence agency, not a
business agency. Thank you, excuse me, that's a
derogatory term. That was
n't the function, sorry,
excuse me. There are people on the
ground who gather information,
people who are connected to the
population, people who walk around, who go and gather information
to find out what's happening,
if there have been guys with
Kalashnikovs. There are people who do that,
there are people who gather
information. These people are starting to
loosen their grip a bit, meaning that the
chain of command, the flow of information...
Information isn't being respected. What do
you think about all this?
Listen, I'm going to tell you about an episode
that was recounted to me because I became
very interested in the reasons, how to
put it, at the beginning of the Franco-
Iranian relationship after the 1979 Revolution.
Remember, Romelu Lumpur was in France when he
came back on an Air France plane. There was
this extraordinary demonstration with
3 million Iranians in the streets,
and so on. They were applauding, along with
the captain, who was making
announcements about CETA. So, a kind of
love affair where every day in
front of the French embassy there were
white flags, and so on. Well, and then,
in a few months, we found ourselves alongside
Saddam Hussein and we were
Saddam Hussein's main supplier. So, what happened
between the
two? And while talking with someone who
was in the ministerial offices at that time,
he told me, "Listen, I
arrived in Iran in '78, something like
that,
'79. My ambassador..."  He left his post, and
the head of the GSE (General Security Service) post left his
post. The ambassador wrote his will, his
letter, if you
will, in which he explained the
conclusions he drew from his stay in
Iran, and in which he said, "The
Iranian cat seemed to me a visionary
head of state, a visionary to whom the brightest
future is promised," and so on. Two months
after the
Revolution, the head of the GSE post said, "
Iran is a country where
1% are French-speaking—those are the ones we see
all the time—2% are English-speaking—that's what we
see, but a little less—and there
are 97% non-native speakers whom we
never see. What happens next? That's where it gets
interesting." To
answer your question, he was
reprimanded by the Quai d'Orsay, who told him, "That's
not the official line of
French diplomacy." He was reprimanded
by his own administration, saying, "
Don't forget that our mission is to
provide raw intelligence." You see...  The
reason I'm citing this example is because
a system's capacity to take
into account something that represents a break
is extremely difficult. You're going to
explain to your minister, "Mr.
Minister, you know we're completely messing things up.
Either you change your
assignment, you disappear
from the cabinet, or your minister is
intelligent, he stops, he
listens, we do what?" But what I mean is,
you have both types of
scenarios. You still have to realize
that there's a
factor that political scientists never
use in explaining the
world: the stupidity of
the individual. A real-life example to help you
understand: the genocide in
Rwanda. The genocide breaks out, the ambassador
there talks about rumors.
Well, we saw what happened next. The fact remains that
we find ourselves in an
international situation where the Americans no
longer wanted to intervene because of
Somalia, the Black Hawk Down affair,
and so on. So Clinton
completely turns a blind eye. The other Western countries
say, "Africa isn't ours."  Et
cetera, and France, which had been one of the
countries that most supported
Aburimana,
as it was a period of—
not collaboration, what do
you call it—when there was a
left-wing government and then a
right-wing government, and then, in the middle, a
cohabitation government, pardon me, it just so happened that it was
a
cohabitation government, meaning that Aburimana,
who was the most pro-Africanist, if you
will, was
challenged by Baladure and Juppé,
who absolutely wanted to prevent the
genocide from happening. So you see the
internal division within the French government.
Ultimately, Juppé and Baladure prevailed, and
so Operation Turquoise was put in
place. Operation Turquoise consisted of
trying to create secure zones
so that the refugees could remain in
place and be protected. I know this
because I participated in its
design. Well, it's a Sunday
afternoon in the office of the chief
of staff. So, in the office of the
chief of staff—it was
Lesutard at the time—only chiefs, with
the characteristic, generally, of chiefs.
That is to say, who had never set
foot in Rwanda since, obviously, their
careers were based in Paris. You did
n't ask people, in addition to being
on the ground, how much are
these people paid?
Sorry, how much are they paid? It's not very well
paid in the administration. 5,000, 6,000?
What? 5,000, 5,
6,000? No, I don't think so. I think it must
be much less than that. For a
director of central administration, it
must be around €1,500 per month,
I think. Okay, I'll wait. I think I'll
give you a figure like that, but
wait, let me think. What would that be? That would be
20,000 per year. No, it's, I
might be below that. That's something that doesn't add up.
I'll give you the
figures, but we're not talking about
private sector rates, are we? And so,
the head of the military cabinet
explains the deployment of
French forces who are to arrive on the ground
to secure areas. He uses
a fairly simple line of reasoning, which is a
military technique.  He said in Goma, in the
Aïr Mountains, there's an airbase, so
we'll position ourselves there and deploy
in northern Rwanda because it's
simpler in terms of communication and
troop deployment. The
only person in the meeting who had no
reason to be there was
the only person who
knew Rwanda; he was an
academic whom a guy from the "
intelligent" cabinet, in this case Jean-
Christophe Ruffin, had brought to the
meeting. So this guy listened to all this;
nobody had much to say because
nobody was capable of criticizing
the military technicalities, and he raised his
hand and said, "Listen, excuse me, but
if you position yourself in northern Rwanda
today, there's nothing left in
Rwanda because they've all been
massacred; they've taken refuge in the
southern hills. So if you position yourself in the
north, you'll keep pushing to
explain that you're there to save
the TCIS, but none of the belligerents will
believe what you're
explaining since they already know, and so
they'll think that, once again, the
French  They intervene because they come to
try and save the regime
they have always supported, the regime
of the... well, if this guy hadn't been
in the room, everyone would have given
the explanation I just
gave you because we always assume that decision-
makers are rational. We're
not going to explain that people don't
know the country and therefore
make such an important decision in
human terms, but simply out of stupidity.
And that's terrible when you're a
political scientist because if you have to
take people's stupidity into account, it
means that part of your
scientific rigor has disappeared, and yet that's
an important element of the last two
questions. It's precisely one of the things I'm going to come back to: is it through this
same stupidity that
you could
explain a kind of ideology that
continues to lead us into
wars that are not at
all, I would say, of any interest
whatsoever for the country and Europe in
general? Well, I'll be more polite than
you, let's say it's a lack of
international culture.  He put it like
that, but basically the question is perfectly
legitimate. Let's take the case of our
president today. His
international experience was about belonging to
the international community, going to meetings
of the Socialist International where
Mbarak and Ben Ali were present. Well, that's all,
I've given you a quick overview.
So this lack of
international experience is, in particular, the idea
that a country has a culture, a
kind of social cohesion, a relationship to
war, and so on, which means that
we can avoid
questioning the necessity of
using armed means. The second
characteristic, which is somewhat a
consequence of the picture I painted earlier, is that there is
no
strategic enemy today, and therefore the
real decision-making criterion is
domestic public opinion. If you
have a media intellectual writing
an article about a country, saying things like "We
are all Ukrainians" or "We
are all Libyans," then the
politician reads the newspaper in the morning when he
arrives and thinks, "Good heavens, what should I do?"
You see what I mean?  What I mean is, it's
not a rational process; it's
become a process of, how to
say, geopolitics of
emotion. The deadliest conflict
since the end of World War II
is the Congo conflict: 25,000,
2.5 million dead, 25,000
child soldiers, sex slaves, and so on.
Whoever talks about the Congo conflict, it's too
complicated. They're Black people, we don't know, it's
the M23, who knows, who, you see what
I mean? So it's not the
gravity of the crisis that motivates this, it's the
media's perception of the
crisis, and that's what's dramatic, right?
And so, instead of having a kind of "
C," this grandeur of Degol, which could at
one point have said, "But the crisis, we
must take into account its
political characteristics before
deciding," here we decide based on what
public opinion will think of what
you are doing. Do
you think we should stay
in the
past? I don't know, you just got us
out of the thing, from what he called...
If you want to take us back there,
the history of
NATO is quite interesting because
when, in 1991, the USSR decided to
dissolve the Warsaw Pact, and in 1989,
the Western powers had
implicitly accepted the dissolution of
NATO. This didn't happen, as you've seen,
and above all, the
Russians had stipulated that there should be no eastward
expansion of NATO. You
saw what happened next. So, we're in a
system, once again, that completely disregards what the
other side thinks. We'll
find them, we'll
consider them threatening, unpleasant,
aggressive, and so on, without asking ourselves if
we ourselves generated this aggression,
this spitefulness, this reaction. That's
the intellectual process. Why? Because
we invented something remarkable in the
1950s, let's say,
called international public opinion.
It's a remarkable
idea because every time we speak,
we speak in the name of international public opinion.
The countries that voted for the resolution banning  The
airstrike on
Libya represents 9% of the
world's population. The others either
abstained or voted against it, but this 9%
represents international public opinion.
So, each time, we
justify ourselves, if you will, by explaining
that we are there because we are
the white knight, bearers of all
universal values. That's the
intellectual process I'm referring to. And so,
the lack of international culture—that's it.
Can you summarize
international opinion?
Well, it's going to be difficult to
formulate
this in a nutshell. It's made up of
people, let's say, lulled by the
Hollywood version of the White Knight, the
good American who comes to save the
little girl, with this same
projected value system. So, it's, let's
say, 9%—to be a bit vulgar—9% of the "bourgeois
bohemians" of international opinion who
vote, having the purchasing power to
influence X or Y
leaders. Is this the
armed wing of our politicians,
this famous international opinion that we
can manipulate?  Corsam, we
either bombard them with anxiety-inducing rhetoric or with feel-good sentiments.
Listen, in any case, it raises a
question that deserves more in-
depth analysis. That is to say,
indeed, but you're right to formulate it, to
formulate the
question, I have to
note, we can clearly see that we
find the same character, BHL, who
starts the war in Libya and then
brings people back to the new
Ukrainian power, to the
new president. So there's something that
deserves to be
questioned, but what makes
these individuals so notorious? So what's
interesting is that you have
a certain number of intellectuals
in positions of power. That is to say,
when you have the same individual who is on the
board of directors of Channel 7, who
is on the World Electoral Committee, and so on
and so forth. Have you seen the
new Gard? Yes, yes, I saw it. What did
you think? Ah, I
found it very good.  REC, we
see it on
TV sets, recommend it, oh yes, yes of course,
I saw it, I found it, do
you know Naomi Clin, it rings a bell,
the shock strategy, I don't know that, well,
I
highly recommend it and I suggest we do another
show on this
concept, one last question just to
finish on your topic, in the
seduction strategy you
mentioned, that is to say, the relationship with the United
States, just two or three things so
that your listeners remember these
things: the relationship to war,
Americans lost fewer people
in all the conflicts of the 20th century than
deaths due to
gun ownership within the United States, well,
when you have on one hand 20 million
deaths in Russia and you have less than
a million deaths in the United States,
the relationship to war is not the same
because you never refer to 39-45,
yes to 39, no, no, all the wars of the
20th century, all the wars of the
20th century, including Vietnam, there were
148,000 deaths during World War II. There were approximately 190,000
American deaths and 169,000
Belgian deaths. How many Russian deaths?
20 million. Very good. And so you
have something that is
quite fascinating, that is to say, when
war has never happened on your
territory, when you don't know what
a bombed city is like, you don't know what
ration tickets are, you don't know what it's like to search for
water sources,
and when your culture has always been mediated
by Hollywood, your relationship to war
and the decision to intervene armed
is completely different from that of the
Russians. Well, I listened to an interview with
Jean Gabin. You know that Jean Gabin
was in Hollywood at the time when
France lost the war, and that
he finally decided to go to London to join
the Free French Forces.
He  He did it discreetly, he didn't
boast about it, he left, he went
to the British consulate, he
asked to leave for London. He
found himself on one of those convoys,
you know, the North Atlantic ones, which
were under submarine fire,
torpedoes, submarines,
bombing raids, German action,
and so on, and he was clenching his buttocks because
he was terrified.
Just before leaving, he had seen
a film about those
North Atlantic convoys, and one of the captains
of those ships was Unfrey Bogard, and
Unfrey Bogard was commanding in the
storm, obviously, meaning they were firing
from all sides, but he was there, he
kept his cool. And Gabin was thinking, "What an idiot
this Bogard is, what an idiot this Bogard is!"
And that's what war is like when
you've always known it.  Through
cinema, you can't have the same
relationship to war, that's one thing, yeah,
but now we have Jack Bower,
you know Jack Bower, another aspect is that
today
every week you have an
American superhero saving the planet, so I
proposed, precisely in the
creation of the enemy, that we have
super intellectuals or BHL, but doped
or not doped, oh no, no, no, super
intellectual, it's the P concept, it's
the new concept, it's the new
means of weaponry. I proposed that we do
a twinning, BHL and Stalin, yes, and
that we send them to Afghanistan, to have a look
at the term, genetic or not, no, no, no, I don't want to do
genetic manipulation, but BHL wrote
two articles that I found in Le
Point explaining how to
resolve the Afghan crisis, and I
use this argument for the courses
I teach at Sciences Po. I bought Rambo 2,
Rambo 2, it's the moment when he returns to
Vietnam because he  There are always
American pilots imprisoned by those
Vietnamese bastards, and he's going there, we're going to get
him, obviously, and he says this
time we're going to win—
classic far-right argument: if we
lost, it's the fault of their bureaucrats
and politicians. And in the film, he
kills 72 guys, 72! So obviously he kills
himself, right? I mean, with a
bow, a pistol, a machine gun, a
flick of the wrist? No, no, no, no!
Because at one point he
cuts his hand, yeah, really! And so
the heroine has to treat him, but
since the heroine is Asian, she has to die. He can't
come back, he can't bring a woman back
there. Okay, but imagine for a minute that we
made a film like that about
Algeria, a guy who says, "We're going
back to Algeria, this time we're going to
win," and who kills 72 Algerians. Can you
imagine the political scandal that would cause
in France? And we take it?  Yes,
but it's not a big deal, it's an
adventure film. Look at the
psychological disconnect, the relationship to
violence, in particular, the relationship to
violence. Of course, the
American hero is obviously the hero, the good
hero, who is more muscular than the bad
hero, than the villain. Okay, we'll
finish the interview. I'm going to
ask you just two quick questions. The
first one is, I give you a word
and you say "tacotac," what does that make
you think of? The Barin Barag is
the very example of the black hole of
Western strategic thinking, occupied
by the Saudis who repressed the
majority of the Shiite population to
re-establish a Sunni monarchy. So it's
part of those
foreign interventions by our allies that we don't
talk about.
Saudi Arabia is pretty much the
intellectual North Korea, meaning it's the
same mindset: everything is forbidden. You
have to go to
Saudi Arabia to see what it's like, you know? I mean,
the only distraction is the
Bachar Mall.  alAssad, uh, I'm
just finishing up on Saudi Arabia, and
so on Saudi Arabia, it's a
fantastic, how to say, it's a
fantastic, how to say, black hole, once again,
of Western strategic thinking.
Purchase, uh, Bashar al-Assad, no, no, no,
purchase in France by
Qatari capital, that doesn't bother me as long as it's
managed. For
example, when Qatar decided to
create an intervention fund for the
French suburbs, as long as
the government said okay, but it would
be 50/50, or even 50 plus one
vote on 50%, I have nothing against it. We're
short of capital, and so that doesn't bother me,
provided that, once again, it's
monitored, managed, and done in accordance with the
philosophy of the French Republic.
Bashar al-
Assad is interesting
because it shows how
difficult it is today to do things in
black and white like we did during
the Cold War, because
suddenly we ask ourselves, which of
the solutions is the...
Worse still, when you don't know the worst
solution, the best is
not to intervene. We've never managed to
stop a civil war through
external military intervention.
Gaddafi, Gaddafi, Gaddafi—I admit that
we were in the same situation there too. No
one could truly
foresee the disintegration of the country once
they
disappeared. So, a kind of
fuse was lit. We didn't know
the intensity of the explosion,
but we're coming back to something that
should be one of the observations we need to
make today: we must
stop overusing the military
when we don't want to bother with
political analysis. John
McCen is the French
fry maker. Laurent Fabius—well, Laurent Fabius
is interesting because it's the
trajectory of those types who, precisely
today, are among the
neoconservatives who came to power,
who don't refuse any re-examination of their
own policies, while the
Americans are normalizing
their relationship with Iran for reasons
Besides, we understand, right? Because we
need the Iranians to
resolve the crises in Afghanistan,
Pakistan, Lebanon, Syria, and Iraq, which
is quite something. We still have
a president who stands alone at the bow of
the Titanic, saying, "I know how to put the
world to rights." Well, the problem is,
you know the rest of the Titanic
story, right? Okay, last question:
if you had to leave a message in a
bottle on the
internet, we'll make you mortal
today. If you had to leave a message in a
bottle on the internet for
the younger generations, do
you have any advice to
give them, something to maximize their
intellectual defense against the
dialectic of
Newspeak? It's an extremely
difficult question, right? Because there was already
a first slogan that had
extraordinary popularity: "
Indignez-vous!" (Time for Outrage!) by C. Fanel. I would
tell them: work, study, watch,
learn. It's really the only
protection we have today against
this kind of flood of
immediate information. Give yourselves time to
think, reflect, plagiarize, yes, and
above all, learn.  Learning, learning, that's what
this kind
of society is all about, this paradoxical situation
where we might say, "But at 20, you
can be a billionaire if you become a
footballer or a crooner, you suddenly
become a billionaire." So, if
you will, there's a degradation of
knowledge here. These trajectories are
incredibly
seductive for young people, but we
can never avoid
knowing, even when faced
with difficulty, what
stance to take. Look at the
scandal during the
Occupation. It's easy today to
say you should have been in the Resistance,
but the people who faced this
problem—it was 3 or 9% of the
population—had to have this
kind of critical distance that meant that a guy, who
was, nevertheless, a
right-winger, even an extreme right-winger, a
monarchist at the beginning, decided that
France was something other than Pétain. And on the
other side, we have a Pétain who had
basked in his glory, etc., who could
seduce the majority of the population
because he was the  Savior of
France, this kind of individual examination
that makes us position ourselves on
values ​​after acquiring
knowledge, that's the real challenge
for the independent person today.
Pierre knows this, thank you, thank you to
[Music].
From the moment we allow
operators to do what they want
on the network, in
fact, we allow them to modify
society, we allow them to modify the
way people interact.
Better and better, there are more and more
opportunities, more and more knowledge
and talent, more and more
solutions, and more and more capital
for projects. What's currently
lacking is that in
many countries, the
institutional framework is evolving to include
civil society in the debate, and we are
very far from doing that in France. I think it's even a bit of a
terror for
institutions.